[Music]
hello Su TV family and welcome to I'd
like to know our Bible question and
answer program we are so very glad that
you chose to spend just a little time
out of your no doubt busy day with us
and we hope it will be profitable in
fact we know it will because the answers
to your questions will come from the
word of God my name is CA Murray I'm in
the company of Pastor Steven bore and
Pastor David
Salazar and of course you are here and
that makes everything wonderful and
complete as we noted this is a Bible
question and answer program so this
program could not be this program unless
we had your questions and our answers
and so would you if you indeed would
like to be part of the program we
encourage you to do so and to contact us
at tvsm
tv.org that's
tvsm tv.org and we will get to your
questions just as soon as we can making
you the promise that the questions come
from you and the answers will come from
the word of God we always try to put
that little uh thing in there because we
want you to know it's our minds and your
minds are good minds but they're just
human Minds what we want is a word from
the Lord and that's what we promise to
give you when you ask your questions
because uh our pins don't really matter
it's the word of God that we can base
our faith on and that will take us from
Earth to heaven so gentlemen Pastor bore
if you would begin with prayer we will
launch out into the questions we've got
a number of questions and before we
start we want to TIY up one question
from um Mia in London that was left from
a number of questions that she had sent
uh that we dealt with last time so
Pastor let's
pray let's pray Father in heaven we come
before your awesome
throne we come humbly but we come
boldly because we come in the name of
Jesus amen amen we plead with you to
please be with us through the ministry
of the holy spirit because only the
spirit who inspired the word is able to
explain it to us amen and through us to
explain it to others so be with us
according to your promise we pray in
Jesus name amen amen and amen as we
mentioned Mia had written a number of
questions this is the last of the four
Mia is writing to us from London and we
thank you uh Mia for letting us know
where you are writing from that always
helps us out just a little bit um she's
got a fairly long Preamble which I think
I'm to pass by because her question
really is
um she's comparing the lot of the angels
with the lot of of of human beings in
the in the Sin issue and the sin
problems um the angels have been created
individually and have chosen one by one
to follow Jesus or
Satan in the case of humanity by the sin
of one she's coming from Romans here uh
all have been condemned
why haven't why we haven't been in the
same situation um
as situation and we are all in this mess
and Jesus had to die so she's saying the
the Angels one by one had a chance to
follow Christ of Satan we know oneir did
two3 did not but in case of human beings
by the sin of one the race became
condemned and of course Christ had to
die to fix the sin problem and she's
wondering why it could not have been
like like the
Angels well the bottom line is that the
Angels had to individually
choose uh whether they were going to
follow Christ or they were going to
follow Satan so it's still a matter of
individual
choice now uh the question as to uh the
fact that human beings are all infected
by the original sin of Adam we suffer
the consequences
in other words uh we inherit a sinful
nature uh I don't see that happening
with the angels because the angels Don't
procreate and so there's no transfer of
a sinful nature from one Angel to
another Angel say from Satan to the
other angels and so because there is no
uh no uh you know passing on of an
inheritance from an original Angel to
all of the other Angels uh the way in
which sin is dealt with is
different I I I I love that that that
answer I would also
add Christ had to die because he loved
his creation um um he The Plan of
Salvation was was was formed and
postulated before man ever sinned if man
falls we have this way of Escape um
Ellen White says in steps of Christ
there were Angels who wanted to do that
they wanted to die for man but the sin
was too great and an angel's life would
not suffice so it is the love of God
that that redeems us love sort of got
him into the problem love gets him
through the problem and love solved the
problem yeah he he he it was all a
consequence of of God's love he loved so
much that he created he kept on creating
well he loved so much that he had to
give Man the free choice uh and he is
suffering with us you know he's he's
he's suffering with us and um will
suffer uer until sin is eradicated from
from the earth so it it's love but the
fact that Angels didn't procreate is is
crucial because they have nothing to
pass on uh to to us yeah ell white makes
it very clear that when we get to the
kingdom there's not going to be
marriage in other words there's not
going to be the process of inheritance
and uh of course when Jesus had the
debate with the Sadducees about the
resurrection uh he said your example of
seven men who married the same woman is
totally irrelevant because uh because
the angels Don't procreate and so so
there's no original angel that
transfers uh the the sinful nature to
the succeeding Angels uh with the angels
it all was an individual choice and they
were expelled because of their
individual Choice uh so I think that
that would explain the reason why uh
according to the question
the the situation of the Angels is
different than the situation of human
beings of human beings yes yes amen
Pastor anything you want to add or I
would like to just sort of inject this
concept too that I think is relevant to
the question um we have through Adam
receive the consequences of sin the
sinful nature and it does put us in
emnity with God as we understand from
the
Bible however that did not stop the Lord
to perform the act of Salvation and do
and start the Plan of Redemption to send
his own son to die for us to restore and
bring a possibility open the door for us
to regain what we lost so you know if we
compare ourselves with angels and we
sort of say well you know I didn't have
a choice uh I I didn't have a choice to
elect being good turning to evil I'm
actually bad and you know giving the
choice now to elect the good well God
has provided enough in his word and
through the grace of Christ and his
sacrifice that gives gives us an
opportunity to truly you know escape
this condemnation this this
hereditary consequences of sin by
accepting Christ so we in a sense and
Christ knowing our infirmities knowing
our weaknesses knowing how uh you know
and helpless we are by ourselves has
provided through his gospel through the
grace of Christ the power to overcome
and to have victory over that hereditary
tendency hereditary sin that you might
receive from your from your you know
nature from your parents so even though
it may seem that we are at disadvantage
over the angels in a sense through the
power of Christ we can be more than
conquerors we can receive the power to
overcome and Christ understanding our
needs is asking us to go boldly before
the throne of grace to receive the power
to escape the sin and Escape that that
element of hereditary tendencies that we
are are are are Bourn with so in a sense
I I feel that looking at the plan of
Christ and Redemption we don't have to
feel that we are in a disadvantage
necessarily over what the Angels did and
the angels chose to follow Satan well
they're lost for you know forever for us
opportunity now today is we have a Plan
of Redemption Christ gives us the
opportunity to be saved through him you
know it's interesting that um God bore
long with Lucifer and with the angels
probation did not close for them they
could have returned yeah but probation
did not close for them until they had
made an irrevocable decision and then
the door of Mercy closed and from that
point on they're all going to be
destroyed MH likewise God has given
human beings a period of Mercy mercy and
Grace when they can come back yeah and
if they don't come back the door
probation is going to close and there's
only be going to be two groups like they
were in heaven when the Angels the
Unfaithful Angels were expelled yeah and
uh the wicked will be destroyed yeah
because they did not choose During the
period of Mercy to come back so I like
what you say that human beings have the
opportunity to to come back through
repentance through confession of sin
through uh faith in Christ and through
the power of the Holy Spirit they can
come back but the time is coming when
the door of probation closes where they
won't be able to come back exactly yes
yes you know we we we talk so much about
one man getting us in Romans takes pains
to say yeah but one man got us out amen
you know we we we got in through one
man's fault but we we we got we we we
had the the promise of redemption
because again one man gave us the hope
of of Eternity so you know it's in it's
out but both one man so amen God has
born long with coming to Christ yes is
the key for the angels and for us amen
yes amen and amen but it's a good
question and thank you Mia for your your
thoughts and your your words uh well
done now comes Derek uh who is writing
from Zambia uh I am Derek from Zambia I
would like to know about the
investigative judgment who is
investigating who okay
if it is being investigated how can God
how can God who knows everything about
me from before we are born up to when we
die he knows even my thoughts Etc how
can he investigate me it's a good
question uh and and it touch on touches
on predetermination and predestination
God does know um but we don't know and
what we need to answer it in sections
who is investigating who okay who's
investigating who God is investigating
everybody you know before this is done
all cases will be decided before the
second coming before the second coming
he investigates only those who profess
Christ and profess Christ right but but
by de facto when he comes uh his reward
is with him so those who profess Christ
will get the reward but those who who
also uh have rejected Christ will also
in a sense get that reward yeah but
they'll they'll see their case after the
Millennium precisely so that they they
are sure and know that God acted
correctly precisely
um one of the things we will be doing I
say we because I'm assuming I'm in I'm
I'm praying to the Lord I'm pray to the
Lord so I'm going talk like I'm in uh is
is seeing during that time that God
chose fairly and CH chose justly uh and
did the right the right thing yeah I
would like to sort of just you know kind
of go back to the Book of Ecclesiastes
12: 13 and 14 is a is how the book ends
and you know Solomon says this to us it
says let us hear the conclusion of the
whole matter fear and keep fear God and
keep his Commandments for this is the
whole duty of man for God shall bring
every work into judgment with every
secret thing whether it be good or
whether it be evil so we understand and
I'm sure that Derek understands the that
there is a judgment that takes place but
why the Lord has to investigate knowing
if he knows everything about us it's not
that the Lord the Father the God needs
to uh investigate something that he
already knows about but it's so that it
can be a very fair and
open uh investigation it's is a part of
the pre-advent uh judgment that he has
to see those who who have professed to
follow the lord who have confessed bless
his name who said that they are
Disciples of Christ to see if their
actions are truly in harmony with the
Lord if they're surrendering their life
to Christ and this investigation it's a
process for the world for the records of
Heaven to know each individual case if
the Lord will just keep this sort of
like you know let's say that the Lord
decided to say you know since I know
everybody the end of the beginning I
know pastor C is going to be you know in
heaven Pastor B is going to be in heaven
Pastor David is not going to be in
heaven so I'm just going to you know
decide who comes and who goes it it
would appear as his character is one of
making decisions arbitrarily but God
opens this time of Investigation so that
not only each human being has a chance
to confess and come to the Lord and ask
forgiveness and also for angels to see
the work and and the decision of
individual you know person a so that
there's nothing can be hidden from from
the world from the universe about the
choices of each person so as God brings
everything you know to light in judgment
every secret thing he's not he doesn't
need to know or he doesn't need to be
aware of the secret things because he
already knows but he needs to reveal
that and open it to the universe to know
who is worthy who's actually choosing to
follow the lord and who is holding on to
sins and trying to hide them from you
know from the world but at the same time
just continuing in sin so it's it's a
process of being opened and God's
character being shown as a one who has B
bong with the human race has done
everything to save someone from their
sins and from their condemnation and in
spite of all the efforts of God and his
angels and holy spirit to work in the
salvation of men they reject his call
reject his admonition his love and
eventually they deserve their righteous
destruction because the rejected Christ
so it's it's the process of of realizing
what God already knows but the world has
not seen or the universe has not
seen our system of Juris
Prudence is based on the Divine
principle of jurist prudence
MH in our courts these days there's
three stages to the
Judgment number one is the
investigation in other words the
attorneys present the evidence
examination of the evidence that's the
investigation MH then based on the
evidence that has come to you the
sentence is given MH and then after the
sentencing comes the execution of the
sentence God has the same system of
Juris Prudence God investigates the case
when the case is finished he pronounces
judgment yeah and then the reward is
given according to the evidence that was
examined in the Judgment now in a trial
the important guy is the the attorney
that you
get that's
right you know um if we claim Jesus as
our attorney M he's never lost a single
case amen amen absolutely but if we try
to represent ourselves you know they say
there's no greater fool than the one who
represents himself and judgment yeah so
if we if we uh you know contract with
Jesus to be our attorney mhm we have
absolutely nothing to fear amen now uh I
want to read just a statement about who
is judged before the second coming and
the reason why God has to judge before
the second coming those who claim to
have believed in his name is because
Jesus is going to come to get those who
claimed his name who truly claimed his
name there's an urgency to do it before
he comes absolutely
the other group The Lost there's no
urgency because they're not going to go
to heaven at the second coming anyway
right so here it says in great
controversy page
483 as the books of record are opened in
the Judgment the lives of all who have
believed on
Jesus come in review before God
beginning with those who first lived
upon the Earth that would be Adam the
first one who lived mhm our Advocate
presents the cases of each successive
generation and closes with the living
that's the Judgment at the very end you
know those who are alive uh and then of
course after the second coming the
wicked remain dead they have not
received their reward because reward is
second death not first death correct and
so and so what happens during the
Millennium God's people will examine the
cases of the wicked 1 Corinthians 6 1:3
yeah and they will pronounce sentence
upon the wicked along with
Christ but there's still group one group
that needs to see uh everything and that
is those Wicked people who remain dead
during the Thousand Years yeah so after
the Thousand Years in panoramic view God
is going to show the cases of all the
wicked and why they were lost mhm then
he's going to pronounce a sentence of
death and then the sentence of death
will be executed now why does God do
this God knows who's going to be saved
and who's going to be lost from eternity
right
in fact Revelation
17:8 says very clearly that the names of
the wicked were not written in the Book
of Life from the foundation of the
world so God already did not write their
names not because he made that choice
but because he knew in the future the
choices that they were going to make yes
that that's the important point and and
so why does God perform this work of
judgment if he knows everything he
already knows who's going to accept
Christ and who isn't it's like you were
saying
because God needs to convince the
convince the universe that is not
omniscient that he acted correctly in
each and every single case yes what
would it be like if we went before a
judge um and there was and the judge
says I don't need a jury I know
everything uh you're I condemn you to
the electric chair you know what what
would people say yeah they afraid hold
it yeah how do we know that this
individual is guilty and reserving the
electric chair we want to see the
evidence see the evidence so the
universe wants to see the evidence let
me just read one text I know I've talked
a lot continue 1 Corinthians chapter 4:9
uhuh says for I think that God has
displayed us Paul is saying God is
displaying
us uh the apostles last as men condemned
to death for we have been made a
spectacle the the word in Greek is
theatron
no there's this is like a theater
production that people are watching so
it says uh for we have been made a
spectacle too now the word world there
is Cosmos M Cosmos and then it says made
a a spectacle to the world and then
explains that the world is composed of
two the word the word Cosmos means the
universe universe and so it says both to
angels and to men amen so God is a God
who wants everyone to be on the same
page when it comes to the saved and lost
and Pastor as you mentioned you know
it's also important for the the saved to
know that the process went you know had
this this process of of of finding out
investigating each individual case
because you would have questions if you
end up in heaven and you don't see maybe
your your spouse or maybe the pastor
that you know passed away and you were
brought to the Lord by the pastor you're
like why is the are not here you know
there were there would there would be
questions that only by having a record
of the Judgment which the Lord will
grant opportunity for every human being
to to see as well as you mentioned to be
able to know and say oh the Lord worked
you know all he did to reach the soul
and the life of this individual person
but that person chose to reject him and
this is of course speaking of the ones
you mentioned that there are the the
Believers in Christ the Believers in
Christ that are are first judged in this
judgment or the pre investigated or the
investig
judment yeah it's it's a a good thing um
it's an exercise in transparency uh
Universal exercise in in transparency
you know sort of glass notes we we want
to see all things and understand all
things right I have been following the
Lord for a few years I I know God doeth
all things well but God is not going to
leave it up to to to me to my knowledge
he's going to show you I do all things
well here's the proof you know you're
going to have a chance to see it for
yourself uh and that's a good thing uh
throughout the universe so that when it
sin is done and sinners are destroyed
there will be no doubt anywhere in God's
vast universe that God did the right
thing the correct thing and he did all
things well and that's why God
um uh spent a long time in Mercy to
Lucifer in
heaven God could have uh snuffed him out
right away but doubts would have
remained in the minds of the Heavenly
beings so God has allowed the
development of sin in this world so that
the loyal beings of the universe say wow
independence from God is a
disaster and so really it's a I don't
know if I should use this word the
vaccination of the universe yeah but it
is the way but but it's a holy good
vaccine indeed it is you know something
occurred to me the other day and then we
we'll move off of this but it just uh
occurred to me that U God's been
suffering with sin a long time he knew
it was coming MH from the foundations
before the foundations so he's been
following that and suffering with sin a
long time and the only thing that that
got him through it is his love for man
and the fact that when this experiment
in sin is finally done it will never
rise again amen will never come back and
we can praise the Lord for that well um
good time good answers good questions
amen uh gentlemen well done again we
encourage you you have a question we'll
try to wrestle with it from the word of
God and we promise you we will come up
with an answer again from the word of
God because that's what we need in these
last words we need the truth the whole
truth and nothing but the truth amen and
that comes from the word of God our time
is fast slipped into eternity allow me
in closing to wish you both Grace and
peace through our Lord and Savior Jesus
Christ we'll see you again soon bye-bye
and God bless
[Music]